hi it's Veda if you're not sure what
that is it's vlog every day in August
which brings me to the question that you
guys keep asking just E are you doing
Veda I can't ever get my dog taken for a
walk and we need to go for a walk
because he's definitely gonna move about
his little belly has been upsetting him
this week has been a little real rough
week for him he hasn't been feeling well
I've taken this dog to the vet four
times like in the past month I clearly
don't have to take him that many times
but if there's any sign of anything that
seems out of place I'm taking him this
misses a little food from before he
didn't need it so back to that question
of just seeing it are you doing Veda no
don't get distracted eat your meal so am
i doing Veda that feels better he'll
keep barking at I don't know putting on
your business doll I got this this could
potentially be the best invention ever
what'd you think of it inspect I'm not
he's not eating his breakfast let's go
go test it out look ma no hands
let's go let's walk good boy
I look like a crazy person I've got his
little water bull's bags definitely a
crazy job mom alert but hands-free I
could play Pokemon go
great got him and we're still walking
Matty has met some amazing friends I
took him to a new park today it's not
really a dog park it's like a person
park but also dog friendly he has made
so many friends he's so popular it's so
hot out and like can we please go home
now you wanna go home are we gonna
snuggle or what are we gonna do you want
snuggle with mommy
I was just thinking about what game I
miss and I did not play enough of was
Mario maker that game was so freakin
awesome I'm not even sure like you
people still play it or people still
into it would it be weird if I started
playing it again so I feel like I
definitely didn't play it enough and
then by the time I unlocked everything I
got busy and wasn't able to even play
the game so here we are I want to start
my gaming channel back up my goodness it
takes so much time to shoot and record
and edit and I don't have an editor and
I don't really want one but like I do
but like I don't else trying to do like
daily videos on my main channel I say
this as I decide to watch something on
the TV I started this show I forget what
it's called Hugh Laurie and Tom
Hiddleston tit I'm on episode 4 it's
called a night manager
suggesting are you gonna do Veda or I
usually only watch shows when Jenna's
here because she's always watching
Netflix and watching something on TV so
I usually will just watch with her and
then I get hooked on the show and then I
have to end up watching it so as I told
you guys ago I was watching the show and
then I watched her episode six and guess
what episodes was the finale
I know Maddie I'm pretty riled up as
well I would all I wouldn't every time I
go to Talk everyone every time I say
something yeah what I'm trying to say is
I would have enjoyed the last episode
had I known it was the last episode I
didn't it was a finale maybe did you
know why don't you tell mommy why you
told mommy it was a finale Maddie do you
know Jenna's coming over yeah I've been
telling her the last hour the Jenna's
coming here and he's so excited about it
yay guys I've got something really
really really exciting to unbox for you
today oh you don't know I know what it
is
what could be in here air conditioner
filters yay up being an Adult School
when I order these I ordered wrong size
I ordered the wrong freakin socks I just
this is the right size got you I copy
get you today on our walk what yep I
changed this one already but I think my
downstairs air conditioner is not
working
nope definitely not oh gee Oh dirty go
ahead great
she's good now all right well I guess
I'll end this vlog it's time to go to
bed I'm sure you guys are all wondering
Justine are you doing Veda Manny what's
your bone okay goodnight
time to edit this video oh look just
somebody want to come to bed with me so
cute
newest eyeless invaded was 100 new
emojis replaces gun with water pistol
I am completely just unsure of how I
feel about it